vamos a hacer más problemas este año
ustedes obtuvieron un aumento del 5% si
ustedes saben que su salario nuevo es de
45 mil cuál fue su salario antes del
aumento bueno vamos a escribir esto como
x es igual al viejo salario y el aumento
es del 5% sobre mi viejo salario así que
aquí voy a escribir x +
5 % de x
y este va a ser mi aumento
y esto va a ser igual a 45.000 45.000
dólares de salario anual bueno ya tengo
mi problema expresado como una ecuación
y ahora vamos a manipular esto de manera
algebraica el 5% se refiere a 5 entre
100 y 0.05 aquí lo escribimos 5 entre
100 5 por cada 100 si hacemos esta
división nos va a quedar 0.05 y ahora
vamos a reescribir nuestra ecuación 1 x
uy qué fea x déjenme reescribir la ahora
si 1 x más 0.05 de x va a ser igual a
45.000
uno de algo más 0.05 de ese mismo algo
va a ser 1.05 de x 1.05 de x igual a
45.000 y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
dividir ambos lados de la igualdad entre
1.05 aquí 1.05 esta parte de aquí se
vuelve 1 y nos queda x igual a 45.000
entre 1.05 sacamos nuestra confiable
calculadora y escribimos 45.000 entre
1.05 y nos queda 42 mil 857 punto 14
vamos a redondear lo aquí 42 mil 857
dólares
es nuestro sueldo anual antes del
aumento y no olviden que siempre es
recomendable verificar nuestros
resultados vamos a tomar este valor como
nuestro sueldo antiguo y vamos a
multiplicarlo por 0.05 para obtener la
cantidad del aumento y esto le voy a
sumar mi sueldo antiguo que es 42 mil
857 el resultado va a ser un número
aproximado ya que no incluir las décimas
pero como ven es casi 45 mil es 44 1999
punto 85 así que lo resolvimos
correctamente ahora hagamos este otro
problema cuesta 250 dólares poner
alfombra en un cuarto que mide 14 x 18
pies cuánto dinero nos va a costar poner
la alfombra en un cuarto que mide 9 pies
por 10 pies no sé si alguno de ustedes
ha tenido alguna vez la oportunidad de
alfombrar alguna habitación pero
normalmente el costo está en función del
área de la habitación a alfombrar y
vamos a usar esta información del
problema
el costo de alfombrar un pie cuadrado
aquí lo escribimos costo por pie
cuadrado en el problema nos dice que
tenemos 14 pies por 18 pies vamos a ver
cuántos pies cuadrados tenemos aquí 18
por 14 8 por 4 32 aquí arriba va el 34
por una 43 son 7 aquí ponemos un 0 18
por una 18 aquí lo escribimos y lo
sumamos 2 +0 27 + 8 igual a 5 aquí
ponemos 11 más 1 igualados y nos queda
252 pies cuadrados vamos a escribir el
resultado que acabamos de obtener aquí
esto nos da 252
cuadrados si vemos que nos tocan 250
dólares para alfombrar 252 pies
cuadrados nos damos cuenta que casi nos
va a costar un dólar por pie cuadrado
vamos a hacer la operación 250 dólares
entre 250 y 2 pies cuadrados y para
encontrar resolución sacamos nuestra
fabulosa calculadora y escribimos 18 por
14 igual a 252 estuvimos bien y ahora
hacemos 250 entre 252 y el resultado es
de 0.99 20 centavos y ahora vamos a
escribir el costo como una función del
área
entonces escribimos cbs s de superficie
no no no mejor escribimos cd
va a ser igual
vamos a ver el valor en la calculadora
para asegurarnos que lo escribimos bien
0.99 2 por el área en pies cuadrados
recordemos que es la variable del área y
ahora vamos a calcular cuántos pies
cuadrados se encuentran aquí
a es igual a 9 por 10 90 90 pies
cuadrados y ahora sustituimos este valor
en nuestra función ce de 90 va a ser
igual a y dice ahorita les puedo decir
que va a ser un poquito menos de 90
dólares el resultado pero aún así vamos
a hacer la operación 0.9 92 por 90
hacemos la operación 0.9 92 por 90 igual
a 89 punto 28 centavos así que aquí lo
escribimos el resultado es 89 dólares
con 29 centavos si yo hubiera escrito
este problema y hubiera puesto esta
cantidad como 250 para tener como
resultado un dólar por pie cuadrado
hagamos otro problema más si cuesta 12
dólares entrar a la feria de san diego y
cuesta 150 subirse a un juego
sirena gasto 24 dólares en total cuántas
veces se subió a los juegos
bueno pues anotemos los datos son 12
dólares más 1 punto 50 por cada juego
vamos a ponerle aquí una erre y ahora
vamos a escribir esto como una función
el costo en función de la subida a cada
juego nuestra letra r el costo en
función de cada juego va a ser igual a
12 + 1.5 por ere y en los datos del
problema nos dicen que este costo total
es igual a 24 y ahora si ya tenemos
completa nuestra ecuación y vamos a
resolver el problema
comencemos simplificando esta expresión
vamos a escribir aquí en 12 más 1.5 por
ere igual a 24 y ahora vamos a restar 12
en ambos lados de la igualdad aquí
escribimos menos 12 y menos 12 más 12 es
igual a 0 nos queda 1.5 por r
a 12 ahora dividimos ambos lados entre
1.5 y el número de veces que se subió
los juegos va a ser igual a 12 entre 1.5
el resultado de esta división es 812
entre 1.5 es 8 así que esta jovencita
rena se subió 8 veces a los juegos de la
feria pero aún no hemos acabado vamos a
verificar que este sea el resultado
correcto usemos la ecuación el costo de
subirse a 8 juegos es igual a 12 + 1.5
por 8 12 más 1.5 por 8 es 12 y 12 + 12
es 24 que es nuestro dato original y
ahora resolvamos el último problema la
suma de los ángulos en un triángulo es
de 180 grados
si el segundo ángulo es el doble de
tamaño del primer ángulo y el tercer
ángulo es el triple del tamaño del
primer ángulo cuáles son las medidas de
los ángulos en el triángulo visualicemos
el problema aquí tengo el triángulo y x
va a ser mi primer ángulo aquí nos dicen
que el segundo ángulo es el doble del
primer ángulo por lo que será 2x y el
tercer ángulo es el triple del primero
por lo que será 3x que más información
tenemos bueno sabemos que la suma de
estos tres ángulos debe ser igual a 180
grados vamos a escribir esto como una
ecuación x más 2 x más 3 x igual a 180
vamos a sumar nuestras x
y aquí voy a poner un 1 para que sea aún
más claro 1 x + 2 x + 3 x va a ser igual
a 6 x 6 x es igual a 180 dividimos ambos
lados de la igualdad entre 6 y tenemos 6
entre 6 186 nos queda x es igual a 180
entre 6 igual a 30 así que nuestro
primer ángulo x va a ser igual a 30 si
nuestro primer ángulo es igual a 30 el
segundo ángulo es 2 por x
igual a 60 y el tercer ángulo será de 90
hagamos nuestra comprobación si tengo
este triángulo con ángulos 30 60 y 90 la
suma de todos estos no deberá dar 180 si
hacemos esta suma veremos que si en
efecto suman 180 y vemos que
efectivamente el segundo ángulo es el
doble del primero y el tercer ángulo es
el triple del primero así que todo nos
salió correctamente